[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu en nuestro
estudio Rosa buena mañana de lunes y por
supuesto vamos a abrir esta revista de
prensa en Brasil repasando las
principales portadas de los medios de
comunicación de ese país y empezamos por
el estado de minas como lo estábamos
conversando con nuestra enviada especial
a Sao Pablo Ángel la Gómez un estado muy
importante y que digamos que Define
presidente de alguna manera en estas
elecciones Buenos días Raúl exactamente
hoy vamos a centrar esta Crónica como
bien lo decías en el resultado de las
elecciones presidenciales de Brasil en
que Lula ya es presidente electo del
país y cómo vamos a ver aquí detrás no
su foto ocupa las portadas de Brasil y
de alrededor del mundo como decías
estado de minas titula Lula derrota
bolsonaro y será presidente de Brasil
por tercera vez y destaca que es la
primera vez que un presidente es electo
para tres mandatos así como también es
la primera vez esto hablamos desde el
establecimiento de la democracia en
Brasil que presidente en este caso
bolsonaro no es reelegido para un
segundo mandato una cita del asignación
Silva que encontramos en la portada de
este medio de comunicación dice es
preciso reconstruir el alma de este país
por lo que uno de sus principales
objetivos en la gestionan del nuevo
gobierno será pacificar Brasil así como
combatir el hambre recordemos uno de sus
principales legados de sus primeros
mandatos entre 2003 y 2010 Bueno qué
dice extra rusa vemos Esta portada con
el retrato oficial de Lula no diciendo
vuelve precisamente este retrato a va a
volver a colgar de los edificios
institucionales del país 12 años después
de dejar el Palacio de plan alto Lula
gana la elección más disputada de la
historia desde el establecimiento de la
democracia como decíamos con unos
resultados Pues sí muy ajustados no que
finalmente han quedado con un 50,9% de
los apoyos a favor de Lula y con un 49,1
a favor de bolsonaro traduce en una
diferencia de unos dos millones de votos
y también citan a Lula cuando dijo
intentaron matarme el vídeo pero estoy
aquí para gobernar el país una frase que
pronunció en su discurso de Victoria En
referencia no a este tiempo de prisión a
que pasó radiantemente cuyas condenas
finalmente Fueron anuladas por la
justicia de Brasil
dice no existen dos a brasils es hora de
bajar las armas también una cita de Lula
que dice que gobernará para los 215
millones de brasileños y que sin embargo
teme el boicot en la transición de poder
no porque precisamente como decíamos los
resultados han sido muy ajustados y
bolsonaro no ha parado de reiterar
ataques por controlar la fiabilidad del
sistema electoral del país por lo que no
se sabe cómo va a acabar de reaccionar
porque tal y como dice el correo
brasilense tal y como destaca de momento
bolsonaro se mantiene en silencio no
dice este medio de comunicación que hago
las luces del Palacio de La Alborada de
la residencia presidencial oficial de
Brasil y que no atendió a nadie y
precisamente es una de las cosas más
esperadas no Cuál va a ser la
pronunciación de bolsonaro cuando abra
la boca en relación a los resultados a
su derrota en estas elecciones y la
fuela de Sao Paulo dice Lula es elegido
por tercera vez la izquierda vuelve al
poder tras seis años no tras el
impeachment de Dilma roussef en 2016 y
destaca que los líderes internacionales
y a felicitaron a Lula y que el
bolsonarismo sin embargo triunfó en Sao
Paulo con la elección de tarcisio como
gobernador bueno Rosa y nos quedamos
precisamente con esta fue la Sao Paulo y
veamos Qué dice en su editorial sobre la
victoria de el Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
un presidente también Bueno un
mandatario digamos polémico no y todo
también las acusaciones de corrupción
que tuvo detrás que dice entonces la
escuela de San Pablo titula las
editorial con en el centro Lula y dice
que la alternancia en el poder es un
signo
digamos que la democracia está sana no
de buen estado de la Democracia del país
y dice que el triunfo de Lula se debe
principalmente a dos cosas al rechazo
dice firme y justificado hacia bolsonaro
por gran parte de la población y por
otro lado la memoria no el buen recuerdo
de sus mandatos entre 2003 y 2010 dice
sin embargo el contexto en el que ASUME
el poder Lula es muy distinto al de sus
dos primeros mandatos a nivel interno
cuenta con mucha más oposición en el
legislativo y a nivel internacional Pues
el contexto es de inflación de guerra en
Ucrania de crisis alimentaria o de
riesgo de recesión por ello coincide con
carta capital que dice que espera que
pronto se conozca el gabinete
Ministerial de Lula y que refleje una
amplia diversidad política que permita
la gobernabilidad del país No dice en
esta línea fue la elección de geraldo
admin como su fórmula vicepresidencial
quien había sido un rival de Lula y
también que Lula dialogue con Ciro Gómez
o con simonet candidatos en la primera
vuelta su apoyo a Lula en la segunda
análisis del país sobre la importancia
Regional de esta victoria de la
izquierda en Brasil de Rosa Sí dice el
país no señala que por primera vez las
cinco principales economías de América
Latina estarán gobernadas por la
izquierda que el triunfo del Lula en
Brasil se suma al de Gustavo Petro en
Colombia al de Manuel López Obrador en
México al de Alberto Fernández en
Argentina y al de Gabriel borich en
Chile dice una alineación a que no había
coincidido antes dice la izquierda
latinoamericana endereza el rumbo y
supera así el traspié que supuso el
rechazo a la nueva constitución en Chile
No dice este resultado además de
reflejar la lucha de la izquierda contra
la Ultra derecha a nivel global también
tiene importante dimensión geopolítica
en la región y que pues estas grandes
economías regionales se podrán unir
tanto en sus relaciones económicas como
en la protección del medio ambiente como
en su relación con Washington no
rápidamente vamos la foto de las
portadas internacionales exactamente
es el Wall Street journal al Granma de
Cuba que dice Lula donde el pueblo lo
necesita y donde asegura este medio
cubano también lo necesita América
Latina y el mundo a página 12 de
Argentina que dice la Alegría no es Solo
brasilera dice como macri en Argentina
bolsonaro se va con la mancha de ser el
único mandatario que no consiguió la
reelección o el corriere de la cera de
Italia Lula reelegido presidente en un
Brasil dividido roto no A ver pues qué
tal está gobernabilidad Y qué tal la
respuesta de bolsonaro cuando se
pronuncia sobre la selección y lo vamos
a analizar a Rosa con nuestro primer
invitado al día igual Muchísimas gracias
como siempre por la revista de prensa
esta mirada a toda la prensa local
internacional de estas importantes
elecciones en Brasil rosas Hasta mañana
hongos